My name's Steve Souders,
I work at Google.
And I work on web performance.
I try to make web sites faster.
I've been doing this
for about four or five years.
I've been at Google
about a year and a half.
Before that, I was
at Yahoo for eight years.
And all the talks--I do about
15 or 20 conferences a year.
And for the last year,
all the talks
have been titled
"Even Faster Web Sites."
But it doesn't mean
all the talks are identical.
And in fact,
today is the first time--
So I have, you know, 20 or 30
different performance tips.
And I talk about a different
set, depending on the audience,
or what I haven't
talked about recently.
And I've been saving back
one set of--one performance tip
for Google I/O because it was
researched by my office mate,
Tony Gentilcore at Google.
So I really wanted to set
that aside for Google I/O
and, you know, pay tribute
to Google by releasing it--
revealing it first here.
So the talk today
is three parts.
I preamble a little bit
about performance,
and where I focus on
performance,
where I think
you really need to focus
to make a big dent
in page load time.
And then I dive into these
performance best practices.
Today I'll be
covering three of them.
And then I wind up with a little
punch to get us motivated
to go home and
make our web sites faster.
And here's the URL, I'll have it
on the last slide as well.
Or you could just
go to stevesouders.com,
and you'll see a link next
to Google I/O to these slides.
So you don't have
to take mad notes or anything.
So I think one of the biggest
things that I've contributed
to the world of web performance
is getting people to focus
more on the front end
than the back end.
When I started my career
at Yahoo, and before Yahoo
I was mostly building big
backend architectures--
databases, data feed systems,
large web sites--
I ran my Yahoo team
for three years.
And about four or five years
ago, the folks at Yahoo
asked me to start a group to
look at making web sites faster.
And that, I'm embarrassed
to say, was one of the--
Well, it wasn't
the first time,
it was maybe
the third or fourth time
that I fired up
a packet sniffer.
So here's a packet sniffer
called IBM Page Detailer.
And you can get
a limited version for free.
And the horizontal axis is time.
And the vertical axis
are HTTP requests.
And so we can see,
we start with--
of course the first HTTP request
is for the HTML document.
And we have these
little icons over here
that give us a clue
of what's being downloaded.
And a style sheet, a script,
and a bunch of images.
And what I noticed, when I first
fired this up on my Yahoo
about four or five years ago,
was that a disproportionally
small amount of time was spent
on what I call the backend part
of this page load.
So the biggest, most backend
intensive part
of fetching a page is generating
that HTML document--
the HTML,
and the other components
that are inside of that.
And so that's where
in all of my career
when I was trying
to make web sites faster,
that was the portion
of the page load time
that I had been focusing
all my attention on.
And really--
Like in this case
with iGoogle
with an empty cache,
91% of the time is
what I call the frontend time.
So this is where
the browser is parsing
the HTML, the CSS,
the JavaScript,
applying styles,
executing JavaScript,
and also
doing more HTTP requests.
So there is network time, maybe
a little bit of backend time.
But not that much, because
these are typically static files
that are being read off a disk
or out of memory cache.
So we see 91% of
the time in this situation--
iGoogle with an empty cache--is
spent on this "frontend" part.
So, you know,
maybe four or five years ago,
a lot of attention
in making web sites faster was
in improving, you know,
your Apache handlers,
your C++ code,
your database indices.
And really, that is
just improving this 9% chunk.
So when I noticed this, I said,
"Hm, well maybe this, you know,
longer pole in the tent is the
place we should be focusing."
So I looked at this
a little bit more.
I said, "Well, what if--
what if the cache was primed?"
'Cause really about 80%
of page views for any web site
are done with users
that have a primed cache.
And we still see
that only 17% is getting
this HTML document, which
involves the most intensive
part of the backend work.
And 83% is the frontend part.
So this big white gap
is where there's
no network requests going on
because all these resources
have been cached to disk,
But the browser still has to
read those files off disk.
And if
they're CSS or JavaScript,
parse them, execute them,
apply them, et cetera.
And this isn't just true
with iGoogle or myYahoo,
like I
discovered five years ago.
Here's the Alexa Top Ten.
And we see,
for a majority of these,
less than 10 or 20%
of the end user wait time
is spent
getting the HTML document.
And that actually
includes the request going up,
the backend
stitching it all together,
and all of the packets--
the response coming back.
So that is less than 10 or 20%
of the overall time
that the user is waiting.
So really, if you want
to make web sites faster,
you've got to focus
on this frontend part.
I think that's one of
the biggest things
that I've tried
to promote, evangelize
among
the web development community.
That's having
some positive effect.
So I call that
the performance golden rule.
If you want
to make web sites faster,
you got to focus on this
frontend part, because that's
where 80 to 90% of the page load
time is being consumed.
And there's three
kind of lessons learned
for why, you know, that
you should keep that in mind.
Just a priori probability
there's a greater chance
of making an impact.
You can cut
that backend time in half,
you'd only do a 5 or 10% dent
in the load time,
whereas if you could cut
this frontend time in half,
that's 40 to 50%.
So it's going to be
much more noticeable by users.
The changes are simpler.
If you want to cut
the backend time down,
you've got to replicate
your application logic
across multiple data centers--
database replication.
You've got to, you know,
analyze your database queries
in your indices,
and improve those.
Maybe change your code design,
the way your compiler
options--things like that.
These are multi-month,
multi-year sorts of projects.
Whereas the things
that I evangelize changing
are things like turn on
compression in your web server,
move a script from up here
to down here in the page--
these are changes
that take a person hours,
person days at the most.
So they're simpler changes,
and they're proven to work.
So every week,
I get two or three emails,
at conferences like this,
people come up,
and the typical feedback is,
"I applied--or at my job,
we applied three or four
of your performance best
practices and cut 25% off."
So if you find the ones--
for example, reported by YSlow--
that are
the most important ones to fix,
and you fix
those three or four,
it's pretty easy
to get a 25% speedup.
And I've seen sites get as much
as a 50 or 60% speedup.
So those are the reasons why you
should focus on the front end.
So as I started
this work at Yahoo,
investigating this area--
so now I knew,
okay, well, we want
to focus on making
the frontend time faster.
So where's that time
being consumed?
And what can we do
to cut that time down?
I came up
with this list of rules.
So this was
from doing research,
going around
and talking to other teams.
I found that the same mistakes
were being made
over and over and over again.
I started--as
we fixed these, and we saw
how much of
an improvement it made,
I started
keeping a list of the ones
that most consistently
improved web sites,
and I ordered them in order
of having the highest impact.
So for example,
if you can reduce the number
of HTTP requests,
that's the most important thing
you can do to speed up
your web site in most cases.
So I had these rules,
and I would go around
and do consulting with
different teams within Yahoo,
and there just wasn't
enough time to reach everybody.
So I wanted to make--
capture this logic in a way
that teams could
analyze web sites themselves
and find the best advice
of what to work on.
So I built
this tool called YSlow.
And it started off as
a bookmarklet,
then a Greasemonkey script,
and finally became
an extension to Firebug
with Joe Hewitt's help.
And this is YSlow 1.0.
I haven't updated the screen
dump; I should do that.
And basically, you can run it
on any web site,
and it tells you--it gives you
a grade for each of these rules.
Each of the rules is a link,
so you can click on it
and see a one-page description
of what that rule
is trying to point out.
And then it
analyzes the web page
and tells you
exactly what needs to be fixed
on the web page to raise
the score for that rule.
And so this is really good.
Now people can run this
and get specific lists
of improvements to make.
It's almost like a "to do" list
for your project.
And going a little bit
out of order here,
I started going around
and evangelizing YSlow
and these best practices, going
to companies and giving talks--
Amazon, Microsoft, Zillo--
companies like that.
And what I found was there was
this community of web developers
that really were
passionate about performance
and making
the user experience faster.
And so I talked
to Tim O'Reilly about the need
to create a community for these
engineers to come together.
And that was the start
of the Velocity conference.
Jesse Robbins and I
co-chair that.
I work on the performance part.
He works on the operations part.
And so we had
our first year last year.
It was extremely successful.
Twice as many people
showed up as expected.
And we're doing
that again next month.
And there's a 15% discount code
if you want to go.
And I've got some flyers
up here on stage,
if you want to take something
with you when you leave.
So that's coming up.
So I evangelize there.
Also last fall,
I taught a course at Stanford
called
"High Performance Web Sites."
So I've got 30 hours of slides
that we could go over
in more detail at some point.
And actually,
they just put the--
last week they put the video--
all 30 hours of video of
the lectures are now available
up on the SCPD web site.
In September 2007,
I got my first book published,
"High Performance Web Sites."
It did really well.
It climbed
to the number one spot
on Amazon's
Computer and Internet Category.
And it's
still doing pretty well.
And it's a good book.
I've got it here.
I carry it with me because
I'm a little absent-minded,
and people
ask me questions about it
and I have to look it up.
And one of the things
I felt bad about when
I got the first bound copy
was how thin it was.
I felt a little wimpy.
And I've gotten
nothing but positive feedback
on how easy it is
to read and get through it.
Some people read it
in one sitting.
And so I haven't
been sitting idle since then.
I've been
working on a follow-up book,
called "Even Faster Web Sites."
And that should be coming out
in just a few weeks, June 15th.
And these are the chapters
that I wrote for it.
And as much as I like thin
books, and I hope you do too,
this would be a very thin book.
And I had other chapters
I wanted to write,
but I found I was
just reiterating things
that other experts in the field
had already been talking about.
So I just asked
these people if they would
contribute chapters to the book.
And luckily they said yes.
So we have Doug Crockford
talking about at a high level
the importance of performance
with regards to Ajax,
and JavaScript, and JSON.
Ben and Dion talking about
creating responsive
user interfaces with Ajax.
Nicholas Zakas at Yahoo--
a big JavaScript guru author--
talking about
some more fine grain
performance optimizations
to be made with JavaScript.
Dylan Schiemann runs
Sitepen, the Dojo Project,
and also Comet Daily Blog.
He's here to talk about Comet.
And we're talk--my office mate,
Tony Gentilcore,
wrote the chapter
on "Going Beyond Gzip,"
which today
will be the first time
it's been discussed publicly.
And Nicole and Stoyan,
of course the industry experts
on image optimization, wrote
theimage optimization chapter.
So today
I'm going to talk about
flushing the document early,
simplifying CSS selectors,
and going beyond gzipping.
Okay, so that
was the first part of
the three parts
of the talk--the preamble.
So now we'll get into the meat.
And...
flushing the document early--
or the potty humor rule,
as I like to call it.
So here's a typical waterfall
chart that you might see
for some HTML page.
The first request
is an HTML document,
and it has
some images and a script.
And this is the way
you would normally expect
to see it load, right?
The HTML document comes back,
the browser parses that,
figures out what resources
it has to download,
downloads those resources,
and renders the page.
And the bad thing is that
when the user clicks
on the link right here,
there's nothing that happens
in the browser
until right here, right?
This stuff is coming back,
and all that time
the user is waiting
and the browser is idle,
not really doing anything.
So is there a way
that we can take advantage
of that idle time?
It turns out there is.
In PHP, there's
this function called flush.
In this case, this example is my
web site that's written in PHP.
So at this point in the page--
after I had assembled
the head of the HTML document
and a couple images up
at the top
and a script
that was in the head--
I called PHP's flush function.
And that sends normally, as
you're echoing output from PHP,
it gets queued up
and standard out.
And then finally at some point--
typically depending
on the size of your document--
but typically
when you're done with
your PHP template or script,
then it gets flushed
to the user.
But by calling flush explicitly,
I can get
all of those characters
that have been
buffered and standard out
sent over the wire
right at that point.
And all browsers
will take that partial response
and start parsing it
and acting on it.
So we can actually get
the browser to start downloading
and rendering resources even
before the entire HTML document
has been finished being stitched
together by the backend server.
So this is really powerful,
but there are a lot of gotchas.
If you read the manpa--
the document page for flush
on PHP's web site, you'll
see a lot of people complaining
about not being able
to get it to work.
And so here are
some of the typical problems.
If you have
output buffering on--
That's actually another layer of
buffers on top of standard out.
And so, if you just call flush,
there isn't anything
in standard out to flush
'cause it's been buffered
in this output buffer.
So you have
to call the OB functions,
like ob_flush, to actually flush
that to standard out
and then call flush again.
I go into more detail on this
in the book
and a blog post
I wrote about it.
Typically, you have
to have transfer encoding--
chunked encoding enabled.
And most web servers--
IIS and Apache--
will take care of this for you.
But if you ever
see that it's not working,
if you're
trying to get this to work
and it
doesn't seem to be working,
look for that
transfer encoded chunked--
encoding chunked header
in the response.
If you don't see it,
you've got to get that working
to make it function properly.
If you're gzipping
your response,
which hopefully you are,
and you're using Apache
earlier than 2.2.8,
there's an 8K gzip buffer--
the deflate buffer size is--
is 8K by default.
So you either need to lower that
or have 8K of compressed content
when you call flush, otherwise
it actually won't get flushed.
If you're running anti-virus
software, security software
on your client, or you're going
through an intermediate proxy,
many of them will
not honor the flushing--
the chunked responses.
It'll queue them all up
and hand them all off
to the browser in one chunk.
So you have to check for that
and make sure that
those intermediaries aren't
stopping flushing from working.
And then finally
you'll get through all of these,
and it will work on
IE or Firefox
but not on Safari or Chrome.
And that is if you're chunked--
if your flush chunk
is too small--
and in the case of Safari
if it's under 1K,
or Chrome if it's under 2K,
and in IE it's 255 bytes--
then the browser actually
won't start acting on it.
So you might need
to get over those thresholds
to actually see flushing work.
And it's flush in PHP,
but most other backend
templating language
have a function that
has flush somewhere in the name.
In Perl,
there's autoflush.
Python, flush. Ruby, flush.
So you can probably
find something like flush
in whatever language
you're using.
One other gotcha that
I've tripped across before
is where--here I'm using IE 7,
which will open two connections
per server name.
And this script down here at the
bottom is on a different domain.
But these two images are on
the same domain
as the HTML document.
And so when I called flush,
I expected all three
of the resources--
the two images and the script--
to all start downloading early.
But one of them didn't,
and I couldn't figure out why
because
there's only two images
and it
should open two connections.
I forgot the first
connection to that server
was still being used
by the HTML document.
So until
the HTML document finished,
this image was blocked.
So if you are trying
to get multiple resources
downloaded as
part of your flushing,
make sure that
you're not getting blocking
with the main
HTML document request.
So if I move that image to be
on a different domain name,
then I get all three
of them downloading early.
So I looked across
at the Alexa Top Ten,
and found--I was glad
to see that Google Search
was the only one
that was doing flushing
that was
very obvious in the download.
And so here,
we see we're downloading--
I'm downloading
a Google Search results page.
And we get this image request
that actually starts downloading
even before
the finished search results
have arrived to the browser.
And what this is,
this is the nav logo image,
which is a sprite.
And this is really great that
this is being downloaded early
because that word "Google"
is displayed at the top.
So by flushing it right after
that point in the page,
it start--it kicks off
that image download earlier than
it would've otherwise,
and it allows the browser
to render that top part
of the page, giving the user,
you know,
progressive rendering--
that feeling that the page is
responding to them faster
than it would've otherwise.
So this is a great success story
of how flushing works.
We get resources
downloading earlier
and the page rendering earlier.
So it really promotes
a faster user experience.
Okay, this one's
a little bit longer.
Simplifying CSS Selectors.
So, I didn't pay too--
like, I didn't talk about CSS
hardly at all in the first book.
And up until
about six, eight months ago,
I hadn't spent too much time
researching CSS.
But about eight months ago,
there started
to be more and more discussion
on the popular blogs
about CSS and performance.
And so for this book, I wanted
to dedicate a chapter to that.
And I think the main performance
problem that gets discussed
is the performance
of CSS selectors.
So let me dig into that
a little bit.
So this is a CSS rule.
And we have the selector part:
TOC greater than LI.
The other part--
the actual styles,
is the declaration block.
Each part of the selector
is a simple selector.
And here we have
the greater than combinator.
And I'll talk about these
combinators a little bit more.
So there's different
types of those CSS selectors.
So I'm just going to focus
on that first part of the rule,
the matching part,
the selector part.
And these are in order
from simplest to more complex.
So there's ID selectors.
So this will match the element
with ID equals the toc.
There should be only
one of those in the page.
So this would be very easy
for the browser to match,
should be very fast.
Class selectors--
any element that has
class equals chapter
this rule will match.
Any element that's an anchor
this CSS rule will match.
Now we get into
some more complex ones.
So here we're
using the plus combinator.
These are
adjacent sibling selectors,
so two elements that are
previous next to each other.
If we have an H1,
and the next sibling element
is one with ID TOC,
then this styling will match.
Child selectors--
any list item that is
a child whose parent is TOC,
this rule will match.
This is kind of like
a child selector,
but it goes--
it matches any ancestor.
So any anchor
at any depth under TOC
will be matched
by this selector.
And there's more.
Universal selectors,
very painful.
The star
will match all elements.
Attribute selectors--the
browser actually has to check
for elements
that have this attribute.
And if a value is specified,
does the attribute
match the value
in the selector?
And then these
aren't really selectors,
but I wanted to mention them,
and they do carry
a pretty heavy cost frequently.
Pseudo classes
and pseudo elements.
So these are
for customizing rules
for behavior that's not captured
in the DOM, like hover.
So probably the most popular--
If you do a search
for efficient CSS selectors,
you'll get this result
as the number one result.
And the first sentence reveals,
I think, what previously
had been a little-known fact.
That the way all browsers
match CSS selectors
is not left to right,
as many of us English readers
would've expected.
It actually matches
right to left.
So now,
when we look at these rules
that at first
seemed like they wouldn't
be much of
a performance problem,
we can see that
this could really challenge
the browser's performance
in the loading of the page.
So here, instead of--
like,I have a TOC element
that has six LIs in it.
I'm thinking, "Okay, well,
the browser finds the TOC,
"and then
finds the six elements that--
list item elements,
that's easy."
Instead it's the other way.
The browser has to look
at every LI in the page
and look at its parent
to see if its ID equals TOC.
So depending
on how many lists you have,
that could be
a pretty expensive match.
This one's even worse.
Again, TOC
only had six anchors,
so I think,
"Okay, what's the big deal?"
Find TOC, find the six children
that are anchors.
Instead,
it's the other way around.
The browser has to find
all the anchors in the page.
And not just look
at the parent,
but climb all the way up
the ancestor tree
until it either
finds "ID equals toc",
or it reaches
the document root.
So this is really--it could be
a real performance problem
for browsers.
So this document gives
some advice.
I'll go over
these pretty quickly
for improving the efficiency
of this matching--
CSS matching challenge.
Avoid universal selectors,
that is going
to have a lot of matching.
There's no point
in qualifying ID selectors,
'cause it should only
match one element in the page.
Similarly, you
could customize classes
associated with tags
into a new class.
There's a little
trade-off here.
This is going
to add page weight
and reduce the flexibility
of your CSS a little bit.
So you have to take
that into consideration as well.
A couple of these do that.
So here again,
create a custom class...
a lot of times when
we use descendant selectors,
we really
know that we mean child.
And child is going
to be a little more efficient.
So look at
your descendant selectors,
and see if they
can really be child selectors.
But then again, do we
really need child selectors?
Could you figure out a way
to create a custom class
in that case?
And finally, you might not need
all the rules that you have
if you relied
on inheritance of styles.
So all of this
is mentioned in this document
which really, I hadn't--
you know, I'd been doing
performance stuff
for four or five years.
I hadn't seen this until
about six or eight months ago,
and I wondered why.
And if you look at the title,
this document was actually
written by David Hyatt
for people
working on the Mozilla Chrome.
And I think what's happened is
he wrote this in 2000--
nine years ago--
I think what's happened is
we're finally
getting to the point
where our web 2.0 apps
are getting so big,
and having so much CSS,
and having such
a longer session life
that we're getting
into the same problems
that were happening
nine years ago with Mozilla.
Where we're getting so much--
so many rules
and so many elements in the page
that have to be matched,
that we're starting
to know the performance problems
of the CSS selector matching.
So there were some tests
published by Jon Sykes
about six months ago.
He's since taken them down,
I think.
But he created these tests
that had 20,000 anchor elements
into different levels of CSS.
No styling, had no CSS at all.
The tag test just had one rule.
The class test had 20,000 rules.
So each anchor
had its own class rule.
And then
he took those class rules
and put them
into a descendant selector
and also into a child selector.
And what we see
is for some browsers,
like Safari is the yellow one,
it got, you know,
five times slower, right?
So this is pretty scary.
And IE also did pretty poorly.
But what happens when you
do things at a massive scale
like that, you have
to take into consideration
if the results that
you're looking at are linear
to what you might expect
in the real world.
And here we see that in IE,
there's a cliff at 18,000 rules.
And since these tests were on
the right-hand side
of that cliff--
or from your perspective, the
right-hand side of that cliff--
it really
isn't a realistic test.
So I looked
at the popular web sites.
And for these sites
there are about 1,000 rules
and 1,000 elements.
So I redid the test
at that level,
and we see that there's only
about a 30 millisecond penalty
in having these
more expensive rules.
So that made me think,
"Well, then, are CSS selectors
"really not a problem?
Do we not
have to worry about this?"
And it's--it really is something
that we do have to think about.
But we need to focus on--
what are the types of selectors
that we should be working on?
So the reason that the "DIV
DIV DIV P A. CLASS 0007" rule
isn't that painful--even though
it looks painful, right?
It's five levels
of descendant checking.
This part is only going to match
one element in the page.
Whereas this one,
which actually looks simpler--
Now that we know
they're parsed right to left,
we're going to start with this
part, called the "key selector."
And it's going to match
a lot of elements in the page,
so the browser's going
to have a lot of work to do.
Whereas this one, that might
actually look more expensive
is much faster
because there's only one element
that's going to match.
So the browser really quickly
can discount some of the work
that it's going to have
to do with this one up here.
So I created some--So
here are some other examples.
If you have a lot of DIVs--
Basically, you
want to look at your rules,
focus your
performance optimization
on rules where the rightmost
simple selector--DIV, A...
here it's an attribute,
here it's a pseudo class.
You want
to focus on the rules where
that rightmost key selector
is going
to have the most ambiguity.
It's going to be--require
the most work from the browser
to match it
to elements in the page.
So...all of those tests
focused on how
this matching
would affect load time.
What about reflow times?
That's the time when you change
something in the page,
and then the browser
has to repaint the page,
rerender the elements.
So this we
see happening now again
in the Web 2.0, Ajax,
the DHTML world--
is happening more and
more because we're doing
these DHTML
actions in JavaScript.
And these will trigger
a reflow in most browsers.
So I wanted to look at...
how--what--which of these DHTML
actions would trigger a reflow?
And how painful was that reflow
in different browsers?
And so here's
a list of about a dozen
DHTML actions
that I came up with.
And I tested them
across these browsers.
I haven't done this in a--
in an apples to apples way,
so I didn't want to show
absolute time values here.
So I just used
this 1x placeholder.
So, like, we might
look at IE 6 and 7--
there's a certain amount
of time it takes
if you change
the class name of, say,
a high ancestor element,
like document body.
If you change the class name,
it's going to take
1x amount of time
for the reflow to happen.
But if you change the padding,
it's 4x as long.
And in these tests,
the value of 1x
is somewhere
between 1 and 6 seconds.
So that--changing
the padding in IE 6 and 7
is going to be somewhere
between 4 and 24 seconds.
And this was on this laptop.
So these things
can be pretty painful.
And this wasn't at 20,000
elements or 20,000 rules.
This is at the real world levels
of 1,000 rules
and 1,000 elements.
So the CSS selector
matching and reflow
is something we need
to pay more attention to,
especially the reflow
as we do more Web 2.0 work.
The sad thing is, we see some
browsers, like Opera,
are doing
something really advanced
in how they determine when
they have to do a reflow or not.
And the ones that do the most,
kind of,
willy-nilly shotgun rerendering
are the most popular browsers--
Firefox and IE.
So we need to figure out
what's happening
in Safari, and Webkit,
and Opera.
And try to get
the Firefox and IE teams
to adopt
some of those advances in
doing
more intelligent rendering.
So the wrap-up here--
here's a plot of
reflow time versus total rules.
And I have
a tool that classifies
the painfulness of rules.
Like, is there a key select
something that's going to
match a lot or
just a few elements in the page.
And there's a high correlation
between reflow time
and both of these variables.
So you want to look
at these improvements.
You're going
to have to do some trade-offs
for some of these suggestions.
You might actually
add page weight.
That could slow down the page.
So to really try to focus
on the selectors that have
that most ambiguous
key selector in it.
So don't
change them all willy-nilly.
Focus on the ones
that are going to have
the biggest performance impact.
And you might also want to look
at reducing
the total number of rules
or the total number
of selectors.
That's going
to affect your reflow time
and page load time as well.
All right,
going beyond gzipping.
So Tony's my office mate,
and he wrote this chapter--
Chapter nine of my book
that's coming out.
So in my first book,
"High Performance Web Sites,"
rule four
is gzip components, right?
And accept encoding
and content encoding
were added in HTTP/1.1.
And so what you get is you get
web clients that say,
"I accept gzip, and deflate,
and possibly
other compression encodings."
And then if the server supports
any of those encodings--
those compression encodings--
it can compress the response,
and then send back this
content encoding,
telling the client
which encoding was used,
and the client can
then uncompress that response.
So that all works well, right?
And it's really easy
to turn on.
Here's the line you would add to
your config file in Apache 2.x.
And this would cause all of your
HTML, CSS, and JavaScript
responses to be compressed.
And that's kind of
the main point that I made
in "High Performance Web Sites"
was compression is--
really reduces the transfer size
of these text responses.
It's typically about 70%.
So if you add
a 100K JavaScript file,
it'll drop down to 30K.
All right,
so that's a big savings.
But typically,
three or four years ago,
you would only see
HTML responses being compressed.
But really, any text response
should be compressed.
JSON, XML, CSS, JavaScript--
all of those should have
compression turned on.
But you don't want to do it
with binary files.
It could actually increase
the size of the files.
And this is a chart
I'll show again at the end.
This is a friend of mine,
Bill Scott--
formally from Yahoo,
now over at Netflix--
where on one day, he finally
convinced the folks there
to turn on compression
for HTML, CSS, and JavaScript.
And when they turned it on,
the outbound traffic dropped
in half,
leaving their data center.
And the Ops guys thought
that the site was down,
and everyone was
just getting an error page.
And they paged him.
They said, "The site's down,
the site's down!"
He said, "Nope,
we just turned on compression."
And so you can imagine the
speedup that this results in,
and also the cost savings
that you'd have
from a change like this.
So anyway, everyone's sold.
You know,
let's turn on compression.
So what's the big issue?
The problem is that about 15%
of the people in the world--
even if you turn on
compression in your web server--
aren't going
to get compressed responses.
Why is that?
I just want to
point out here I intentionally
misspelled the word "surprise,"
'cause I think
it's more fun with a "Z".
Like something
that has a prize in it.
You know,
surprise should be happy.
So, this and performant.
"Performant" is not a word,
but I use it all the time.
So I had my spell checker accept
that as a proper spelling.
So, you know,
how is this possible?
How can 15% of the people
coming into your web site
not get
gzip compressed responses?
Well, maybe they're coming in
on old browsers
that don't support
gzip compression, right?
So here's the top four browsers
that don't support
gzip compression.
And maybe they add up to 0.1 or
0.2% of total internet traffic.
So we're still off by 14%--
14.8, 14.9%.
What are all these users
that aren't giving--
getting compressed responses?
So I'll give you a clue.
If you broke this out
by region, most of the people
who aren't getting
these compressed responses
are coming from the Middle East.
Any guesses?
Proxies and anti-virus software.
The other one is the Vatican.
It's like 100% of the traffic
in the Vatican doesn't get--
coming from the Vatican
doesn't get compression.
So what we see
for these requests coming in
from browsers that
we know support compression--
IE 8, Firefox 3,
Firefox 2, IE 6, IE 7--
there's no
Accept-Encoding header.
Or there's not
an Accept-Encoding header,
but there's something
that looks very close to it.
But it's been munged
in some way.
So you can see here,
"X" was added here.
And you'll see this,
where the total byte size--
these proxies
or other intermediaries
want to maintain
the same byte size,
so they won't remove it totally,
they'll just mung it
so servers won't
return a compressed response.
And the reason they do that
is these intermediaries
are trying to filter
the responses for some purpose
to look for, you know,
phishing attempts,
or security,
or undesirable content.
And it's just easier
for them, right?
To look at
an uncompressed response,
then to write that,
you know, include that library
that is going
to handle gzip responses,
and uncompress it,
and then analyze it.
And the thing is
that uncompressing is,
I don't know, five to ten times
faster than compression.
So it's not like it's going
to be a big performance hit
if you have
to uncompress the responses.
And if you looked
at the time it would take
to uncompress the response
versus the time
to download
something that's going
to be three times bigger,
it's a huge win
to have compression turned on.
So I see this all the time.
I don't believe
that the developers
who built these proxies
or anti-virus software programs
intentionally want to
slow down the user experience.
In my experience,
they just aren't aware of
the performance degradation
that they're inflicting on
this group of users.
And so we need
to raise awareness of this
and try to get them
to enhance their products
to not strip out
Accept-Encoding.
So you know, I encourage you
to go back and send me an email.
Check your site.
How much of this
do you see on your web site?
Do you see about 15%?
Is it more?
Are you--Do you
have some way to detect,
you know, what the cause is?
'Cause we could start reaching
out to specific vendors--
especially
the most popular ones--
and ask them to,
you know, address this,
to add compression support
in their software product.
So I looked at my site,
stevesouders,
and I turned on,
for 500 unique users,
this beacon that recorded
not just their headers,
but also some behavior
in their page.
And what I found was
it was around 15%--I got 14%--
were missing
the Accept-Encoding headers.
And of those ones
that were missing it,
they had some munged
version of the header.
1% of them had
a munged version of the header.
And I tried to see
if I could tie this
to proxies or some other tool.
So here are some headers
that I used to do that.
But I want to--really quick...
Let's see, okay.
Yeah, here we go.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
I wanted to show you this thing
that I think is kind of fun.
And it's locked down,
so you won't be able to...
get into it.
So I call it "Dinoquery."
So I think
the most important thing
about any software project is
a cool picture and a cool name.
And so, don't tell
Bam Bam and Fred about this.
But you know, every time
you reload the page,
you get different pictures
of Dino.
But it's
supposed to be "DynoQuery,"
like dynamic queries.
And so it's very crude.
I hope to open sour--you know,
improve this a little bit
and open source it.
But I wanted to show it off
a little bit.
So basically what I do--
Those 500 users, I just dump
their headers and some other
attributes of their experience
into a MySQL database.
And then this Dinoquery
is a PHP script
that's maybe 300 lines of code.
And you can drop it
on top of any MySQL database,
any MySQL table.
And it basically
just enumerates the fields
in the table, and lets you, you
know, poke at them a little bit.
So let's poke at
the Accept-Encoding header.
And we see that
out of these 500 requests,
about 14% of them are missing
the Accept-Encoding header.
And if we
look at another version--
another dimension on
this data--like the user agent.
You can see that these are
perfectly normal user agents
that we would expect
to support compression.
So why don't they have
the Accept-Encoding header?
So one thing we can do--
it's kind of hard to look for
munged Accept-Encoding headers,
'cause you don't know
what they're going to look like.
So basically, any header
that I didn't recognize
that looked weird,
I put into this other category.
And so here
we can see examples of
where they've munged the
Accept-Encoding header, right?
So how can
I try to correlate this
to proxies
or anti-virus software?
So there are some headers
that are most prevalent
with proxies--like Via.
And so, whereas--and this
is another thing
I wish all plotting tools
would do.
Is I always want
to compare plots side by side.
I hate having
to open up two different pages.
So I can look
at my overall population--
what's the distribution
of the Via header?
In my overall population,
I have about...
What would that be? 50.
So I have about 10% of my users
coming in with a Via header.
Here, of these ones that have
a null Accept-Encoding header,
it's about 40%.
So clearly, a much higher
percentage of these users
are coming in through proxies.
Another one we could look at
is proxy connection.
So here,
12 of them have Keepalive.
In the overall population...
it's also 12.
So all 12 of these users
that are coming in
with a proxy connection header
have a missing
Accept-Encoding header.
So this is really clearly
tied--I don't have a good way
with headers
to detect anti-virus programs.
Or if you know a way,
let me know.
But clearly,
this is very correlated
to users coming in
through proxies.
So...
dun, dun, dun, dun.
Okay.
So what can we do about it,
right?
There are some things
that we can do.
And we're talk--Tony
in his chapter talks about
three different
approaches to take.
But I'm going to talk about
one of those--
is basically as developers,
to not assume that compression
is going to happen.
'Cause this is pretty tricky.
If you look at this
15% of your audience
that isn't getting compression,
and you try--and you, you know,
average that across
your entire user population,
the slowdown
isn't going
to be that significant.
But the problem
is that this penalty
isn't distributed
across all your users.
Those 15% of your users
100% of the time
are not
getting compressed responses.
So they're getting a very,
very much slower page load.
So what can we do about that?
So we can't assume
that we're always going
to have compression on.
So there are things
that we can do
that we've
talked about before
but even in my first book
I didn't emphasize that much.
Because I kind of thought,
"Well, compression
will take care of this."
So we can go that extra mile
and do more work
for this 15% of our users,
like minifying.
Like, a lot of times I don't
minify my JavaScript
'cause I know
I have compression turned on.
But for those users,
minification--
If you turn on compression,
you get 70% reduction.
If you minify it
before compression,
you'll get
maybe another 2 to 5%.
So it's not that much.
Well, for these users
that don't get any compression,
the minification will reduce it
by about 30%--30 to 40%.
So that can be significant.
Now let's do it
to not just JavaScript,
but CSS and HTML as well.
Instead of inline styles,
which will add more characters,
try to use rules.
If you have
long JavaScript names--
we see this a lot in the
JavaScript frameworks
like jQuery.
Instead of
document.getElementById
everywhere,
alias that to something
that's shorter.
And if you use that function
again and again and again,
you're going
to reduce characters.
If we had compression,
that would just be an entry
in the dictionary.
It wouldn't matter
how long it is.
But for people
who don't have compression,
it's going to add up.
And we can shorten our URLs
by using relative URLs.
So there are
a couple other techniques
that Tony talks about.
And he's giving a talk,
a philosophy on this topic
with more of the information,
if you want to come
check it out.
Okay, and we're start--So that
ends the second of three parts,
the nitty-gritty
best practices.
So I'm going to start
wrapping it up now.
You know, if you want to make
your web pages more scalable,
reduce your hardware costs,
focus on the backend--
figure out
how to handle more requests
with the servers
that you have.
But if what you want to focus on
is the user experience,
how fast your pages are, and
how they're perceived by users,
you got
to focus on the frontend.
That's the long pole
in the tent.
You can run YSlow,
and it'll give you
specific advice on what to fix.
It's usually the place to start.
There's more you can do
beyond YSlow.
But those are the basics
that are going to have
typically the biggest impact
and are the easiest to rule out.
Speed really does matter.
It improves your company,
your user experience--
I've got a couple slides
that touches on that.
One is faster web pages
affect revenue.
We have three data points
that are kicked around
among my talks and other people
doing performance talks.
There's this
one from Marissa Mayer
where Google--
the Google Search page
became 500 milliseconds slower
and lost 20% of its traffic--
which is
directly related to revenue.
At Yahoo, they just published
this one a couple months ago--
four months ago, they did
an experiment where they
introduced
a 400 millisecond slowdown.
And they saw a 5 to 9% drop-off
in page traffic.
And then Amazon--a former Amazon
employee released this stat.
They determined that
for every 100 milliseconds
of latency that
was introduced in the page,
they lost 1% of sales--
1% of conversions.
So this really
does have an impact on
how your brand is perceived,
and how your web site is used,
and how users are going
to engage with your web site.
And that's going
to impact revenue.
It also affects your operating
costs--your hardware costs,
your data center costs,
your network costs.
So you can imagine if you don't
use a far future expires header,
then you're going
to have many more requests
for those static resources.
But if you fix your expires
header, if you remove ETags,
it's going to greatly
reduce the number of hits.
There's a very big web site,
I won't mention the name,
that didn't have
a far future expires header.
They turned that on and
they saw and 80% drop-off
in the number of requests
hitting their servers.
So you could bypass their next
two hardware purchase cycles
with the servers that
they already had deployed.
And then I showed this one
before about bandwidth costs.
Doing things like adding
compression are going to reduce
the usage of network that you
have in your data centers.
And that will translate
into cost savings.
So...if you want
a better user experience--
how many people want that?
More revenue?
Reduce operating expenses?
Okay, I'll take that.
The strategy is clear--
even faster web sites.
All right, that's it.
[applause]
So we have about ten minutes.
I'll take questions until
about half the people leave.
And then I'll stop
and I'll hang out
for as long as you guys want
to talk about other stuff.
So are there--or I guess
let's try to use the mics.
[man speaking indistinctly]
Souders:
Yeah. Yeah.
So the question was,
what about other kind of
crawlers or screen scrapers?
Could they
be contributing to that 15%?
So, you know, I think,
I know in my studies,
I stripped out all of those
bots, and crawlers, and spiders.
And I think Tony did too.
So these are, like, real users
who are logged-in users.
So those people
could be contributing.
But they're probably, in many
cases, not affecting the us--
it's not real users
who are blocked,
waiting on those responses.
So...
Any other questions?
Yeah.
Yeah, use the mic if you would,
that'd be great.
And can you introduce yourself
and say where you're from?
Shepperton: Yeah, hello.
Yeah, I'm Dave Shepperton with
Traction Software in Providence.
And we build a web-based app--
It's actually
a hypertext journaling system
on the model
of Vannevar Bush's memex.
At any rate,
as to your gzip issue--
or your gzip observation, and
what Tony was talking about,
we saw exactly--we saw
this whole munged header thing.
We saw that--we actually have
an article in our knowledge base
about this,
explaining to customers
why gzip
wasn't working for them.
And we also saw
the phenomenon of a gzip buffer
not filling up, and
therefore the page load times--
when we shut off--
actually, it wasn't exactly
the right thing to do.
I guess we could've
shrunk the buffer
for the gzip output stream.
But when we shut off gzip
compression for HTML documents,
suddenly all these imaginary
performance problems went away.
So that was great.
Anyway.
So my question:
Do you have any information
on how the GWT framework,
you know, uses all this
great performance advice
that you're using?
We're--we're
beginning to use that,
'cause we want a really nice,
rich, interactive environment.
I'm just wondering if you know
what the GW team
has done with that.
And you can speak that
and take my answer off the air.
Souder: Yeah.
So I, you know,
meet fairly regularly
with the GWT team--
I call them GWT--
with the GWT team.
And, you know,
they're familiar with
these
performance best practices.
Some of them are kind of outside
the scope of what GWT does.
And so it's still going to fall
to the responsibility of you,
the web developer,
to adopt some of those.
For example,
like creating CSS sprites.
I doubt that
GWT will ever do that.
They might, like, recommend
a tool, or build a tool
that you could use to do that.
But it's probably
going to be something that--
something that you have to do--
Excuse me?
Oh, really?
So, and I know, like, another
one that I think is coming,
or already in GWT is--
at the talk I did last year,
I talked about the first three
or four chapters of my book,
about loading scripts
asynchronously.
And so most of the frameworks
have functions you can call
to achieve that--
to get scripts to load
without blocking the other
resources in the page.
And so I think GWT
has support for that as well.
So I know
that they're very, you know,
in touch with
making web sites faster.
And they want
to do everything they can.
I don't have the specific list
of what they've done.
And I know they're--I think
Bruce is doing a talk here
about GWT and performance.
I think it's on my schedule
this afternoon to go to.
So you could go and ask him.
I'm sure he's going to talk
about the specifics.
But yeah, they're very motivated
to try to do that.
And that's one of the benefits
of having a framework--
is the more we can get these
performance best practices
evangelized in jQuery, Dojo,
GWT, Wordpress, Blogger--
all these frameworks
that developers
and non-developers are using.
If we can just make web pages
fast by default--
you don't have to do anything
to make it happen.
That's going to
have the biggest increase
in these performance--adoption
of these best practices.
Williams: Jeff Williams,
University of Minnesota.
What do you think of that tool
that they showed this morning--
the performance tool?
I saw you and
your buddies at the keynote.
Anything you can tell any
of the rest of us about it or?
Souders: Yeah,
I think it's amazing.
And I
just mentioned to the fellow
in the front row
who's from Minneapolis
that I'm heading there
over the Fourth of July, so...
You know,
maybe we'll see you there.
Yeah, I think--Well, one,
it's a beautiful tool.
I mean, I love Firebug.
But, you know, it's kind of
showing its age a little bit.
And you know,
Web Inspector, I think,
you know, in Safari,
is a beautiful tool.
And the tool that we saw today
as part of Chrome
is just amazing.
I mean, even ignoring the fact
that they built it on,
you know, kind of standard
web tools--CSS and JavaScript--
is amazing, but
just the work they've done
with the user interface.
And I think that
the thing I appreciate most
about what they showed is...
You know, the YSlow
best practices were great
to focus on
two or three years ago.
Like, turn on compression,
add
a far future expires header...
But you know, people
who are into web development--
that's kind of old hat.
You know, my guess is
people here who are,
you know, really focused
on a faster user experience
have those things done already.
And so what is it
that, you know,
the advanced developers
are working on?
Well, we're all working on
JavaScript,
and we have a heck of a lot
of CSS in our pages.
And yet, these tools that we
have don't give us much
visibility
into how the performance
of JavaScript, and CSS,
and even HTML parsing--
how that is affecting our pages.
In IE 8, there's
some visibility into that.
But there's no
GUI around it.
So that's really painful.
So I think what they've
done there to actually show,
you know,
JavaScript execution timelines--
So not just how much time
was spent doing JavaScript,
but where did it
happen in the page?
I mean, in Firebug,
you can turn on the profiler,
and when you stop it,
you can be told
how much time
it took to execute JavaScript.
But was that at the beginning?
Did it block the rendering
of stuff I care about?
Was it at the end, where I might
prefer to have it happen?
I have no idea.
So yeah, I think
that's an amazing tool.
We're going to see
more tools like that
announced at Velocity.
And I think that's
what web developers really need,
is we need visibility
into this stuff
that we're really
trying to optimize now.
Yeah.
Ed: I'm Ed from Filemaker.
Do you have any further data
about how that 15% breaks down
by region for United States,
Europe, Asia, et cetera?
Souders: Yeah, Tony's
going to talk about that more
at his talk
and in the chapter.
But I'll tell you that
in the U.S., it's actually
surprisingly a little higher
than you would think.
So the worldwide average
is 15%.
I think in the U.S. it's 20%.
And it's very high
in the Middle East.
And actually, you know,
I was kind of surprised,
in Asia is where
it's a little lower than 15%.
But beyond that,
I don't have, like,
a specific, you know,
country by country breakdown.
I'll ask Tony
if maybe he can throw up
a slide like that at his talk.
Hi, huh?
Kyle: I'm Kyle
from UC Santa Barbara.
What are your thoughts
on CSS frameworks
like Blueprint?
How much of a performance
hit or gain are they?
Souder: Yeah, someone asked
me about the YUI reset stuff
at the last conference
I was at.
And I'll be honest
with you, I don't use--
use reset or use
these other CSS frameworks.
So you know, if you email me,
I've got cards.
Email me
something specific to look at.
Like, if you have a web site.
And I'll shoot you back
an email.
I'll, you know, run YSlow,
and fire up my packet sniffer,
and spend an hour looking at it.
And maybe that's something that
we should be focusing on more.
But I don't have
an answer for you on that.
Any more?
Okay, last one.
Oh, two.
Two more.
Go ahead.
Zachary: Brandon Zachary,
Demand Media.
Souders: Where are you from?
Zachary: Demand Media...
eHow, LIVESTRONG, Trails.com,
and a bunch of other stuff.
[nervous laughing]
Is there--have you ever saw,
like, a threshold between,
you know, moving something from
inline CSS to a separate file?
Or would you
just recommend putting
everything in a single file?
Or maybe just
page specific files?
Souders: Yeah, that's
a question I get a lot.
And I think the,
you know, best site
that has struggled with that--
and I don't think has found
the right answer is Facebook.
You know,
I know a year or two ago,
they basically
took all the scripts
that were loaded
on any page in their site
and loaded them on every page.
So if you went to the front
page, you downloaded a megabyte
of JavaScript
across 35 separate script files.
And, you know,
so the advice I give
in high performance
web sites is,
you know,
there's no single answer.
I suggest that if you have--
And, you know, so it depends
on how many pages you have,
and what CSS and JavaScript
is included in which pages.
But it also depends
a lot on user metrics.
Like, if you're
a page like MyYahoo,
where people only come in and
they do one page view, right?
There's only
one page view per session.
MyYahoo doesn't have--
unless you're editing,
or something like that,
or unless
you have multiple pages,
which most people don't.
You know, you go
to your MyYahoo or iGoogle page,
you view your modules
that are on there,
and then you
go somewhere else, right?
So really,
you only have one chance
of serving
that page to that user,
so I would inline
the CSS and JavaScript.
'Cause for that--
You know, the reason
to make it external
is for caching.
Well, maybe that user
is going to come back today,
but if they
come back tomorrow,
or certainly if they don't come
back for three or four days,
they're probably
not going to have
those external resources
cached anymore.
So what I recommend is, you
know, look at the user metrics.
If it's, like,
a very small number
of page views per session,
or page--or sessions per month,
lean towards inlining.
But if you have a site like,
you know, Calendar,
or Facebook, or something
like that where people
are doing multiple page views
per session,
and multiple sessions--
a lot of sessions per month,
Then you might want to make them
external to benefit caching.
And then as far as, like,
when to concatenate or not,
you don't want
to do what Facebook did
and basically include
every file on every page.
And you also don't want to
combine them all into one file.
So you're going to
have to look at the pattern
or what's used and try to
figure out some middle ground.
Last question.
Ovsankin: Hi.
Sasha Ovsankin, IMshopping.
So the question--
I'm coming from kind of
a regular programming
engineering background.
You know C++,
yeah, whatever.
And I'm just
looking at you guys,
you know, working
with all this CSS is--
and it's kind of hard.
You know, handcrafting all
these little details, all that.
It kind of reminds
the working assembly language
when you were, you know,
just working with
calculating the pipelines
of the processor, and the--
Souders: So we're actually
out of time.
Ovsankin: Right.
Souders: Do you want to ask
the question really quick?
Ovsankin: Okay, so...
Souders: Sorry.
Ovsankin:
The question is this:
Are you aware of any efforts
to do this
more on a higher level,
more automatically, so that
you would just, just, just--
Souders: Yeah. Yeah.
So let me answer really quick,
'cause we're out of time,
and then I'll stay after
and we can talk more.
There's two companies that,
you know,
I talk about quite a bit
that are doing that.
One is Strangeloop Networks.
They actually
have a hardware appliance
that I think right now
only works with IIS.
But you put it between
your web server and your VIP,
and it actually changes the
HTML document as it comes out.
It creates sprites on the fly,
concatenates scripts
into single scripts,
changes, you know, your CSS
to use background position,
et cetera, for sprites.
And then
there's a software solution
from a company
called Aptomize.
Their project is called
Runtime Page Optimizer.
And it exists
for IIS and Apache.
And it's a module that you add,
and it will do the same thing.
Before the HTML leaves
the server, it's modified,
and they
actually change the markup
to adopt many of these
performance best practices.
And then they
do also simple things,
like just change
your config to turn on gzipping.
Okay, thanks again.
I'll stay
for any other questions.
[applause]